foreign
[Music]
Mount calf your mission is clear find
Prince Hassan and bring him back to
persepolis
however Mount kaf becomes a prison full
of hostile and have
fun
now separated from your allies you
discover a grand Citadel full of
mysteries where time flows differently
what is this sorcery the past coexists
with the future
this cursed Lynn exploration is
everything
this is a semi-open world that delivers
new Secrets as we find new powers
to reach new areas
to master your skills and your
a trademark of Prince of Persia
during this Epic Journey
you won't be the only one trapped in
Mount calf goddess and blacksmith to the
Gods
some dwellers are willing to help you
While others are more reluctant
[Music]
however Sargon is not a warrior like any
other
[Music]
wild beast
being elusive ruthless and extremely
skillful in the battlefield
[Music]
by anger he constantly puts his life on
the line to perform devastating attacks
time powers are back
with this time
[Music]
not only in your hands
to face such a challenge Master a new
side to these time powers and defy
gravity
foreign
by combining all these skills together
you can express your creativity to solve
Mount caps Mysteries
and execute the combos in that
[Music]
episode
and that's just a glimpse of what Prince
of Persia the Lost Crown is all about
on behalf of the team from Ubisoft
mobile we cannot wait for you to put
your hands on the game
it releases on January 18 2024 on all
platforms
foreign